I didn't know this you dated the hot for
teacher van like a girl and I saw this I
said oh my god David dated the hot for
teacher girl from the van Halen video
this soap she was unbelievable this is
big news to me do you ever go on the
internet and watch the van Halen video
just to remind you I'm so mad at myself
that I messed it up do two of you were
lovers for a short period of time yeah I
guess
well I'm trying to put it I was like a
little pipsqueak from a-z but I was
always shocked that she was so nice and
liked me and she actually liked me
you know what's troubling about being
not 6:40 I'm 6 4 or 5 6 5 6 5 Robin
knows you track your Victoria but it's
really profiling when people see me
because they know they can take me and
so I remember this happens all the time
when you were the girl like I was with
her once at a bar and a guy stepped
between us and started talking to her
yeah
and I was sitting there having a drink
and I go is this guy joking right and
then he and then she goes I'm with him
and he goes okay and she goes well
you're gonna be with me now and I was
like now see here sir well you want to
know something I'll tell you more
humiliation I am six foot five and when
I was in college I dated a girl who was
very very attractive hmm one of these
football player types came up and he
says to the girl you're going out with
him I'm 65 you think somebody'd be
scared of me they're not I know you want
to be like John Claude Van Amburg it's
pressure to date the girl who's hot from
the van Halen teacher video because
you're right guys are gonna like
interrupt I know but then I sort of fade
it out on her and I you know what I
realized you dated everyone I've ever
beaten off to all of them